Oh welcome to this video playing rich be
rich be okay so some English opening
going for a quick d4 oops don't see that
too often literally that early capture
yeah even though okay I mean hmm maybe
if for was interesting 406 yeah it looks
like we just transpose into some kind of
maroc see point I doubt that I mean this
is just like the regular maroc see right
9f 693 takes takes 26 yeah there is no
no particular advantage this is the only
thing that wad can try to try to make
use of that uh huh interesting h6 if i
go back to three can go also to f4 maybe
to a form when you cannot castle
yeah okay we can do that you can try to
snatch my my my bishop only three I was
wondering if c5 maybe is a move here
it's an interesting way to play let's do
that oops and I have to check the door
so how much time did that cost quite a
bit huh what can you do wait a moment we
should be five might be interesting do
that first but ok let's let's go here I
have Bishop b5 in the pocket yeah that
was got something and delivered so I was
actually the Christmas present for my
mother but don't tell her so early on
our ordered earth i ordered it early ok
so i hope that this kind of position is
tricky for black it definitely is i mean
you cannot develop easily and I'm
threatening and whoa that working I can
definitely take 95 I just wonder there's
something better Quincy 7 is also kind
of also not easy for him Bishop c6 maybe
ship c6 might be playable yeah one issue
is that i don't have lots of time
hmm i wonder if taking is really the
right the right way to do it but ok I'm
going to do it so yeah Chad's let's go
here I'm king of a gnite c7 roop the aid
we should be five but just about her
walls it seems ok maybe he has to go as
to walk in his seven now then at least
I'm getting a good end game out of it or
Jenna I don't think I have anything
better it's just just a check yeah
Bishop c4 looks quite dangerous but I'm
not quite sure if I really have a great
discovery ok check it's quite simplistic
but I'm just going for the good night
against bad Bishop him also thinking
about my time this end game has got many
moves that I need that I need to play
but at least I can play those moves
rather quickly
hmm yeah would have liked to check if
rooks is six I wasn't sure about it so I
just played the simple simple method
okay yeah i'm going to take definitely
check now over to see form so I've got
good control world in this position and
one never be three doesn't help want to
try to fix more pawns on light squares
maybe helps me a little bit with move
them flag f4 or something like that okay
it's not sure that this is helping that
much and k is taking mm-hmm interesting
I would like to get an h4 h5 of course
but that's not going to be easy I go
h-hi egos h5 one good thing is that he's
catching up on the clock
and I have Knight a5 if he goes over
with the King I've got 95 in the right
moment attacking c6 and if the sea pawn
moves knight c6 I did I need be three
and one of the next moves that is clear
he can go h5 no it doesn't ok so I get
mp3 let's do this first so how am I
going to what would be good and really
good would be if I managed to get get
him to move the jeep on something like
night over to f3 also seems that it's
not quite sure what he needs to do in
this position so let's see if I can try
to get the knight to f3 right h2 coming
time morning or this coming right
welcome to f3 an all-night h4s is around
the corner ha ha ha lab it's not even it
totally totally clear draw yeah and ok
that that didn't help that much maybe I
have to still do it with 95 IDM cannot
do it now
I wonder maybe h4 h5 still I don't know
let's do this now I got kingi for coming
ok and now the night might be able to
sneak into f5 yeah ok so what you do it
yes and now you can just take it what am
i doing yeah forfeit sorry I was winning
on time anyway when age 6 is kind of
stupid ok I'm kind of interested in this
opening here this idea that I had if it
was any good this is some kind of
uncommon that they go age six here in
this position and I was thinking this is
an idea my Bishop Bishop e3 I mean he
has got 94 immediately and I am wasn't
well if I'm this I mean he gets he gets
the game position with with extra move
so let's try that and not C Phi for him
ok the engine just wants to go look you
one which is kind of simple and not bad
ok but this should be bad huh this is
this okay rook t1 first is also given by
the engine as a good move ok but Quincy
fire as well ok dear I night be five is
good yeah this was the this was when I
was just returning from the job at the
door might be five ok now that's indeed
a good move in this is the thread this
is a threat but will win an exchange
okay check check and this is ok but it's
nothing check brilliant yeah Bishop c4
looks looks good but what what is it
doing actually yeah I mean computer
gives gives just a slight edge after
king ii jus how i did it i know i wanted
a simple positions and this is just
going to be like a little bit a little
bit of a nibble because of my better
night against his bishop looking at that
pawn I mean it should not lose for black
of course but it just led to something
something simple delay this end game is
probably a draw but as you saw in the
game it was simpler for me to play I
could could dash out many moves and I
was quickly yeah catching up on the
clock so we are ultimately I went for
this h4 h5 but still it's not still is
not much and she could have played this
often was I mean it's got 44 m isolated
pawns with it which is good good to play
against but it's probably still nothing
nothing much the engine wants to go be4
funny idea yeah it's probably still a
draw I don't think I can can prove a win
here with analysis okay well thanks for
watching